[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es eine hoffentlich leckere
pizza rezept der partie hat mir neulich
nämlich erzählt dass er pizza essen war
und es war eine ganz außergewöhnliche
mit kartoffel deswegen hieß sie auch
pizza pate also potato auf türkisch auch
patrick und genau die hat der kartoffeln
drauf die wahren eingelegt in rosmarinöl
dann war einem inspektor drauf und
büffelmozzarella und ich habe die pizza
selbst nicht probiert aber ich glaube
wenn der partie später noch da ist lasse
ich ihn probieren und dann kann er mir
sagen ob ich den geschmack so getroffen
habe und vor allem können wir dann auch
probieren ob uns die pizza schmeckt ich
habe jetzt erst mal den pizzateig
vorbereitet da findet ihr bereits das
grundrezept auf einem kanal
ich hab den teig für vier blitzen
vorbereitet mache jetzt heute auch vier
und werde jetzt hier noch eine
tomatensoße herstellen da mache ich
jetzt eine ganz einfache soße ohne
kochen ihr könnt ihr jederzeit ganz
schnell auch mal so zubereiten
dafür nämlich 400 gramm gestückelte
tomaten aus der dose 100 gramm
tomatenmark die habe ich die gewürze
etwas oregano salz pfeffer eine
knoblauchzehe etwas chili und eine prise
zucker dann sind hier die zutaten fürs
mit pesto dafür brauche ich 50 gramm
gezupfte minzblätter ich habe 50 gramm
pinienkerne und grana pagano also
parmesan etwas salz 2 knoblauchzehen und
auch 50 kollegen öl und hier habe ich
noch ein paar kartoffeln das sind jetzt
vorwiegend festkochende kartoffeln
rosmarin aus dem garten salz pfeffer und
einer prise chili etwas olivenöl und zum
belegen dann natürlich auch noch
büffelmozzarella den pizzateig habe ich
ja schon vorbereitet da es im
kühlschrank und dafür habe ich einfach
die hefe menge halbiert ihr könnt den am
vortag machen oder einfach am morgen und
im kühlschrank lagern bach perfekt und
hier kann ich jetzt die tomatensoße
zubereiten dafür werden einfach alle
zutaten verrühren
die knoblauchzehe die presse ich jetzt
dazu
dafür braucht es ja auch nicht schälen
ihr könnt sie hier direkt in die
knoblauchpresse reingeben und auspressen
[Musik]
ich habe hier übrigens auch schon die
kartoffeln ausgesetzt die kochen hier
bereits und ich brauche jetzt auch so
lange bis sie fast gar sind damit sie
später auf der pizza eben nicht noch ein
bisschen rose jetzt mache ich ihnen
derzeit schon mal das mit pesto
die minze waschen kurz und schleuder sie
dann damit einfach das wasser weg kommt
[Musik]
jetzt kurz trocken schleudern oder mit
einem küchentuch also küchentuch
entwickeln ein bisschen trocknen
denn ansonsten habt ihr echt viel wasser
im pastor den käse kleider ich jetzt
groß und dann kommt alles in den mixer
ich nehme es einfach den stabmixer man
sieht auch keine so große menge ist
ansonsten nämlich auch ganz gern den
food prozessor als lot im multi
zerkleinerer die knoblauchzehen die
könnte mit messer so ein bisschen
zerdrücken
dann lassen sie sich einfacher schälen
das jetzt komplett verdrückt netz
schlimm
jetzt gebe ich noch alle anderen zutaten
das so als ob ihn kenne das öl natürlich
und danach langsam die minzblätter und
kann's schon fein pürieren
kartoffeln habe ich jetzt bereits
geschält die haben auch abgekühlt
jetzt kann ich den rosmarin nach dem
halt vorher hast du besser rein gebe ich
jetzt jene schüssel oder in einen topf
da kommt das öl dazu und ich erhitzt das
jetzt kurz damit diese olivenöl rosmarin
marinade schön in die kartoffeln 1 sieht
also nicht kochen nicht heiß werden
lassen sondern wirklich nur ganz langsam
erwärmen und kartoffeln können die
entweder jetzt in scheiben schneiden
oder in würfel wie ihr das gerne möglich
versuche jetzt mal kartoffelwürfel zu
schneiden
[Musik]
jetzt kommen die würfel hier ins warme
schön vorsichtig damit sie nicht
verfallen
ihr könnt doch die kartoffeln gerne
schon am vortag abkochen oder wenn ihr
welche übrig habt einfach zu dieser
pizza verarbeiten
hier noch die kräuter reist dazu daheim
dazu jedoch immer vorsichtig verrühren
und dann wirklich einfach nur noch ein
bisschen stehen lassen damit sich das
aroma entfaltet und damit die kartoffeln
gleich richtig lecker nach rosmarin
spenden jetzt hole ich schon mal meinen
tag raus kann ihn portionieren und die
pizza schon vorbereiten um zwei jetzt
bisher wirklich nicht schwierig also
wenig kartoffeln übrig habt irgendwie
vom essen vom abendessen dann
verarbeitet sie doch am nächsten tag
einfach zu dieser leckeren pizza
jetzt werde ich meine hände mit etwas
olivenöl nehme diesen wunderschönen
pizzateig raus der ist ganz frisch aus
dem kühlschrank
übrigens und ich finde den jetzt falls
ihr euch übrigens fragt was diese
flecken davon sind das ist pfeffer ich
mache nehme ich immer total gerne
pfeffer in den teig so schmeckt nämlich
auch schon richtig schön gewürzt dann zu
einer kugel formen her
es gebe ich olivenöl in maine im mai
quäntchen in meiner gezapft
das ist einfach die pfanne die benutze
ich entweder zum servieren weil ich dann
meine kleinen mini schälchen drauf
stellen kann oder eben zum pizzabacken
aber es war so viel ich vertrags beim
pizzabacken sind die nämlich wirklich
perfekt oder flammkuchen oder andere
herzhafte und süße gepäckstücke denn im
mai könnt ihr ja auf dem herd benutzen
auch induktion und eben im backofen oder
sogar auf dem grill
aber da könnt ihr euch wenn ihr möchtet
einfach mein video anschauen ich habe
nämlich ein video gemacht auf dem
technik kanal und auch eins auf diesem
hauptkanal wo der murat euch einfach
zeigt wo unser immer geschehe herkommt
deswegen ist auch das öl drunter
wirklich wichtig jetzt könnt ihr einfach
mit den händen den teig so auseinander
drücken und gleichzeitig das blech
drehen deswegen sind die halt echt zuvor
praktisch und entweder macht ihr den
rand weg wenn ihr nicht so gerne pizza
schmeckt oder ihr lasst ihn so ein
bisschen dicker und ich lass dir jetzt
ein bisschen dick ich mag mich fit waren
[Musik]
was ist das wichtigste gut
unsere drehte in dem du das so mit
beiden händen auseinander zurück also
quasi durch tristan dass die eigentliche
macht was anderes so es geht übrigens
leichter wenn der teig etwas wärmer ist
also nicht kühlschrank hat ihr könnt den
weg so ein bisschen vor heraußen ist
einfach so ein bisschen entspannt auch
schon aber so klappt super nach pizza
lehre bestanden
vielleicht händewaschen bei uns hier
macht man übrigens auch eine lehre zum
koch und zum konditor los ist gerade im
zweiten lehrjahr
nachdem ich jetzt hier mit meinem
kochlehrling die pizza werden
ausgebreitet habe belege ich sie jetzt
einfach zuerst mal tomatensoße
es wird echt super aus
wenn sie sich ein bisschen zusammen
zieht einfach wieder öffnen dann die
soße verstreichen für wahrscheinlich die
einzige die mit orten palette einer
winkel palette die pizza soße gestreift
[Musik]
ich glaub ich es heute doch tatsächlich
das erste mal kartoffeln auf einer pizza
zu meiner verteidigung muss ich sagen
der partie hat es in dem italienischen
restaurant gegessen
[Musik]
eins muss ich sagen ich würde mir keine
meiner koch videos anschauen wenn ich
hunger habe ich kriege beim kochen schon
jedes morgen
das würde ich echt nicht machen da
liegst du da guck dir das video an und
denke dir so geht's jetzt gehe ich meine
ist das manchmal schreibt ist nämlich
darunter vor allem so mitten in der
nacht wenn man keine zutat oder kriegt
von böse jetzt nehme ich den büffel
mozzarella trotzdem ein bisschen aus der
wir jetzt hier drauf gerupft und da ist
einfach cremiger als ganz normaler
mozzarella und jetzt kommt hier noch das
pesto drüber einfach in klecksen ich bin
echt gespannt vor allem auf die münze
also habe ich jetzt das fest so probiert
ich möchte jetzt nicht meins lastig was
ich aber auch ganz gut finde zu einem
abgang merkt man die minze ein bisschen
und ich glaube dann passt ganz gut
die erste packe ich jetzt schon mal die
restlichen belege ich noch und dann wird
gleich probiert
und ich mag es hier bei pizza stufe das
heißt die unter hitze ist einfach
stärker als die oberhitze schön weit
unten bei 250 grad
so wird sie nämlich richtig gut cross
und sie muss auch nicht so lange backen
wie in einem steinbackofen steinofen
gefahr
[Musik]
die pizza ist fertig die hat jetzt echt
nur zehn minuten gebraucht und unten ist
ja auch gut durch gebacken
ok wat du darfst probieren kommen erste
frage hallo erste schlag ist diese aus
die kartoffel stückchen wollen etwas
kleiner aber weil diese nicht vor
gekocht haben ich hab's dir vorgekocht
weil wenn man sie nicht verkauft kann
man sich ganz klein machen damit sie
überhaupt durch sind auf der pizza und
der mozzarella größer und nicht so
verlaufen
da haben sie denn als großen sie haben
praktisch so große mozzarella stücke
rein oder drauf ich habe es ja auch
drauf aber die sind mit gebacken haben
die vielleicht kurz vor ende drauf das
weiß ich nicht das kann zu lassen ok das
sieht auch gut aus sieht sehr gut aus
ok jetzt probieren wir sehr schmal ihr
könnt ja auch direkt auf dem blech
schneiden und normalerweise würde ich
jetzt sogar sagen man ist direkt auf dem
blech für eine person eine pizza ich
habe es hier was drunter was die zum
beispiel damals gemacht oder was die da
gemacht haben die haben sich so eine
pizza schere dann kriegst du eine pizza
schere und schneidest mit dieser pizza
schere praktisch an deinen auf dem
teller
die stücke die du haben möchtest das
habe ich noch nie gab dem restaurant
okay was zählt ist der geschmack
ich habe noch nie zusammen mit
kartoffeln gegessen premiere und mit
minister ich hab's mir ist auch gerade
ich bin gespannt
gleich ein riesen fan von pizza bin weiß
ich mir die katalanen
aber eins muss man sagen ich habe keinen
holzofen und kein stein offen aber ich
brauche aber unbedingt einen garten dort
ist jetzt nächste bauprojekt draußen
oder freut sich der gummi unter murat
und kann schon so heißen
also ich muss sagen das ist auf jeden
fall wieder sehr gelungen die kombis
einfach perfekt die kommende schmeckt
echt gut habe ich jetzt ja auch gerne
aus dem steinofen oder pizza ofen
probieren das habe ich heute zu hoffen
dass die meisten haben oder im steinofen
steinofen rettung bevor wir uns mit holz
alt und wenn ihr auch diese kartoffel
pizza ausprobieren wollt dann schaut
einfach in meiner arbeit da steht das
rezept für euch und schreibt mir auch
auf jeden fall wie es euch geschmeckt
hat und dann könnt ihr mir gerne in die
kommentare schreiben was eure lieblings
pizza ist also was ist ihr
lieblingsbelag und was soll ich
vielleicht hier auf dem kanal auch noch
mal machen und uns erziehungsbuch knappe
spiele jetzt die kamera weg und essen
jetzt habe ich jetzt wieder wieder
normal ist immer nur die spitze die so
heiß ist und dann der rest aus der hand
jetzt schon viel besser
[Musik]
jetzt fühlt den schmerz jetzt mit mehr
schlimme schön dann sind diese
brandblasen taschen zwei wochen lang
[Musik]